matriarch
momager master of marketing and the
center of a family-owned
empire e.t is taking a look at how
kristin mary jenner
turned her kids into some of the world's
wealthiest stars
whatever kristina wants she gets the
mother of six has been a boss lady since
day one
my job at the beginning of all of this
was to take 15 minutes and turn it into
30.
first managing caitlyn jenner's career
during their marriage eventually taking
on kim chloe
courtney rob kylie and kendall the
manager
manager turning their socialite status
into hollywood royalty with the launch
of keeping up with the kardashians in
2007.
that's it we're done which in turn made
chris a pop culture phenomenon in her
own right kim you're doing amazing push
this knee out
taught kim would you stop taking
pictures of yourself your sister's going
to jail
chris is impersonated for her iconic
moments from the show all the time
but she's definitely in on the joke your
sister is going to
jail angle up sweetie our mom has made
us
share our lives spinny drama what are
you doing
hey chris i told you if i catch you
doing this
one more time little [ __ ]
bye dolls ariana grande even featured
the iconic momager
in her thank you next music video thank
you next [ __ ]
chris's dream of becoming a talk show
host became a reality when she premiered
her very own daytime talk show chris
in july of 2013 and e.t was with her on
set
i'm new at this so i'm just gonna be
chris
and do my thing and try to you know give
150
of my energy to something i've wanted to
do for a really long time
and just do the best job i can and see
where the cards fall
but i think that anyone knew coming into
this
and any of the veterans you know the
people that really
have been doing this for a lot longer
than i there's room for everybody
i think it's going to be a great season
of talk shows chris may have only lasted
one season but her job as a momager and
reality star
kept her busy we tell our own story we
have enough going on you don't have to
make anything up
that you know that's what i always tell
people i'm like you can't make this
stuff up
the savvy businesswoman has been
integral in all of her children's ever
expanding careers
and she's said to earn her 10 percent of
their coin how soon until
this show is announced the kendall and
kylie show well they have to get
good grades they have to show me that
they can handle their own show
and then we have to talk ryan into it oh
yeah so
secrets are you listening yeah ryan are
you listening to me
because they need a show although the
kendall and kylie show never came to
fruition
in 2015 chris helped her youngest
daughter launch her beauty brand kylie
cosmetics
kylie i think you've just launched an
empire
and kylie paid tribute to her mom by
naming one of her liquid lipsticks
kristen this color goes with everything
kylie cosmetics eventually sold a 51
stake of the brand to cody one of the
top multi-national beauty companies
with chris by her side of course for 600
million dollars
yup you heard that right and cody made
chris
chief executive officer of kylie
cosmetics after the sale
one of kylie's dreams when we first
started this journey was that she wanted
to have
an entire line of makeup products one
day
i don't think we ever dreamed that it
would happen
and in 2018 chris got her own
collaboration with kylie cosmetics
and jokingly hacked her daughter's ig
account to announce the makeup line
chris cosmetics
chris was also involved in selling a
stake of kim's kkw beauty line to cody
which earned the family another
200 million dollars they have amazing
work ethic amazing integrity and an
amazing
focus and vision for whatever project
they're working on and i'm just
completely surprised all the time
but it's not all business with kj work
hard and play hard seems to be her motto
oh boy she's always down to pull a prank
we could play practical jokes on people
like what somebody who has no sense of
humor
like you like him you could tp her house
or everybody
and have a few drinks
i think it means you're horny hey
oh this is gonna be a long night so just
buckle your seatbelt
chris is always the life of the party
you never know what's going to happen
she loves wine tasting my mom every time
so far
gets her drunkest at this winery tipsy
karaoke
my mom is the queen of drunk karaoke
who wouldn't want to party with chris
it's an instant party
oh my god another role for the 65 year
old momager she's a grandmother to ted
now everyone's outnumbered me
i'm kind of like lost in the shuffle but
it's a lot of fun now i know
watching you raise your children you're
stern with them but you also spoiled
them a little bit how is chris jenner as
a grandmama
i i'm i'm a spoiler i think i'm due yeah
i'm getting an a
right now i've decided i'm doing great
but and we're also filming keeping up
with the kardashians right now so we're
i see the camera cruise here right there
hello the 20th and final season of
keeping up with the kardashians may end
over a decade-long run on e
but kris jenner isn't going away anytime
soon
she's already solidified what's next
when it comes to television and more
never a dull moment the kardashian
family will continue their reality reign
on hulu in an exclusive deal with parent
company disney
announced last year chris also launched
a plant-based cleaning and self-care
brand with family friend chrissy teigen
and
currently has her own skincare line in
the works oh
here's my hat of course finally
i feel i have finally